it's not
fair I'm talking to you upstairs are you
there you know I
care so please don't tell me that this
is and
empty yeah oh
no cuz all she has and all she's lost I
wish she could
remember I watch her fade and slip away
it's hurting more than
ever I miss
her even though she's still here you
need to
listen don't let her dis disappear I
give her my
forever it been there for a day she
could really be okay cuz I miss
her
oh even though she's still
here is this
pretend will she really I know my face
in the
end
oh you're friend a friend a friend show
me how to heal it when she can't even
feel it
please show
me cuz all she has and all she lost I
wish he could
remember I watch it fade and slip away
is hurting more than ever I miss
her even though she's still here get me
to
listen don't let it disappear I my
forever if for days you can really be
okay as
I and promise me this
when she
goes everything she sees will set her
free 13 and the color green prise
me let see
now that the people that she loved will
love her in his SK
above even though she still here you
need to leave
so don't let it disappear I give him my
forever forever forever if it been for a
day she could really be okay cuz I miss
her even
though she's still
here
oh I miss her miss her miss her I miss
her miss miss her I miss
her even
though she's still
here come on
baby oh
yes oh you know but about the after
part oh
my oh
yeah all
right hey yeah if you know you going to
be hitting the club tonight then you got
to make sure that you look at righty
getting all dressed up to the night with
a fresh